so as we continue our series on the
Marvel Universe vs. the Punisher we pick
up now with issue number two and Frank
castles attempts to track down and
eliminate spider-man so opening up with
Castle engaging in a fight with the
Incredible Hulk Punisher continues the
trend are providing bits and pieces of
backstory to the events that unfolded
during the collapse of society after the
infection of Earth's super-powered
community and normal humans while castle
admit city has avidly avoided fighting
the Incredible Hulk due to his
tremendous strength he also tells us
that following the infection of the
world while castle had been forced to
put down Captain America after he became
infected
Wolverine had attempted to subdue the
Hulk now something to take note of here
is that Mayberry is actually setting a
precedent in relation to adamantium
where Marvel Comics as a whole have
routinely established that adamantium is
considered to be unbreakable one of the
biggest questions that has played comics
is whether or not the unlimited strength
of the Hulk could actually break
adamantium at some point along the line
answering this question while this is an
alternate reality and not part of the
main Marvel continuity Mayberry tells us
that if the hope were made angry enough
he would actually be able to break
adamantium something demonstrated when
he had broken Wolverines arm off and
consumed Wolverine entirely in addition
to this maybe also tells us that despite
his incredible strength
Hulk is not without his weaknesses
taking aim with an arrow and using a
knife as a tip Castle is able to
penetrate the orbital socket of the Hulk
penetrating his brain and killing him in
the process now to be honest I wouldn't
really put too much stock in this since
castle killing the Hulk in this manner
really seems to be more about
progressing the story more so than
anything else especially since the Hulk
is popular enough the fans would
undoubtedly want to see what had
happened to his character but when
Castle is able to neutralize the Hulk
his attention is drawn by a cry for help
from a normal human now as we go forward
into this bit of the story something I'd
like you to take notice of is that
Mayberry is essentially telling us that
there's more going on than meets the eye
referencing our last video and our
discussion on how Punisher simply barges
into situations with no real thought to
the consequences this trend continues
when the calls of help lead him to a
church where he finds a priest and a
young girl house within while Castle is
able to pull them up using a rope in the
midst of his efforts he's attacked from
behind by venom
now I'd like you to pay special
attention to what happens within these
next few pages in that firstly Mayberry
does not tell us whether or not this
version of venom is Eddie Brock while
this isn't the most important thing
those individuals who were venom fans
largely wanted to know whether or not
this was the case to simply see if this
reality had unfolded in a very similar
way to the main mobile continuity about
where Punisher pulls out a sonic pistol
designed to disrupt the symbionts due to
their weakness to sonic vibrations in
the moments before he dies
venom attempts to reason with Cassell
who ignores the pleas and kills venom
without mercy now again the reason why I
want you to keep this in the back of
your head is because this will largely
impact what happens in the next video
but with the priests and the young girl
and Punisher leaving the church the
group travels back to castles base of
operations where the priests provides a
bit of backstory on society's collapse
from his perspective the what he tells
us is that prior to the outbreak he had
ran a soup kitchen in the Bronx feeding
both the homeless and the unemployed at
a sidetrack for a second one of the
great aspects about this story is that
Mayberry is taking real-world elements
and throwing them in as a way to provide
relatability and realism to the events
as they're unfolding what I mean here is
that for those who were unfamiliar with
the economic crisis of 2008 the catalyst
for this class was found in the mortgage
sector due in large part to the subprime
mortgage sector and people buying homes
without any understanding of how
mortgages worked or how to organize
their finances as a result and following
the collapse multiple banks had stopped
lending money to virtually anyone
including small businesses resulting in
massive layoffs and high levels of
unemployment across the country
incorporating this into the story when
the outbreak occurred and humanity began
turning into cannibals the soup kitchen
was turned into a veritable house of
horrors as several individuals began
consuming the various humans inside
taking to the streets and attempted to
save those who appeared to be immune the
priests was forced to both watch
innocent people die but also killed
individuals who attended to harm him or
those who was trying to save in addition
to this the priest went on to explain
the prior to Frank castles arrival their
group had numbered in for including a
woman and another little girl but that
at some point in the night they had
seemingly vanished without a trace
leaving the priests to wonder whether or
not they had left or been taken now the
reason why Mayberry included this in the
story was to highlight the idea that
with society crumbling around them
instead of coming together and bonding
over their experiences instead humanity
is simply doing what they can to survive
and casting aside all ties of dependence
now one of the most important points
made during the exchange between the
priest and frank castle is a castle is
the exact same as the cannibals the
reason for this is that prior to the
outbreak the role of the Punisher in
this alternate reality seems to have
been identical to the mainstream novel
continuity and castle routinely killing
criminals and had amassed a reputation
for himself as a cold-blooded murderer
at the same time the cannibals had
killed without mercy as well meaning
that in the eyes of normal humans the
only difference between the cannibals
and castle was that he didn't eat humans
however in the midst of their discussion
Frank Castle and the priest are met with
the return of Deadpool now our Castle
instructs the priests to take cover and
allow him to deal with Deadpool a funny
little thing here is that Mayberry
depicts Wade as being the same kind of
slapstick mercenary from the mainstream
continuity who cracks jokes and can be a
little over annoying at times in
addition to this where Castle indicates
his intention to kill Wade yet again in
a way that will keep him from reforming
it's revealed that the presence of Wade
comes with a message informing castle
that there are actually more survivors
who have not yet been consumed by the
cannibals furthermore the message
provided by Deadpool states that in the
eyes of spider-man and his ilk the
actions of the Punisher in killing the
various cannibals he finds aren't
necessarily an act of aggression so much
as Punisher protecting his own tribe of
not infected humans now again as the
reader we're aware of the fact that this
is not the case and that Punisher is
killing the cannibals since he was the
cause of the outbreak and looks to
eliminate the cannibals to atone for his
actions but the inclusion of this goes
towards the argument of the priests in
establishing that despite not being
infected Castle operates in the same
capacity as the cannibals themselves and
so we're wait finally gets to the point
of his arrival after rambling on for a
few minutes he informs Punisher that
while spider-man has left him alone all
this time he now looks to have a sit
down and request the help with castle
for reasons unexplained and so where
castle initially questions the offer and
asking why both deadpool and spiderman
would believe him foolish enough to walk
into the Lions Den Wade informs castle
the Spider Man has already arrived at
his location and so as the issue comes
to a close with Frank Castle searching
for the priests and the young boy he
discovers a Spider Man has
held captive in an effort divorce is sit
down between the two with that being
said we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and in the next
video we'll pick up with the outbreak
from the perspective of spider-man as
well as the events that led into iron
man dying after being stuck in his armor
for five days with that being said I
will catch you guys either peace